Physics is about discovering with the
laws of nature are,
and we've gotten some distance towards
that.
We're not done,
but we've gotten some good distance
towards that at the present time.
But once you know it,
the laws of nature are another kind of
question unfolds itself,
which is why are those the laws and not
other laws.
For example,
the laws that we understand,
the standard model of particle physics
describes all the fundamental particles.
They're interactions has about 30
numbers,
which you just have to put in as the
result of measuring them by experiment,
the masses of a different particles,
the quarks,
electrons,
neutrinos the strengths of the
fundamental forces,
various numbers like that.
And the model works dramatically well as
the recent experiments at the large
Hadron collider show,
why are those numbers,
what they are and our universe,
why is a massive the electron,
what it is and not 12 times larger,
half the size.
There are dozens of questions like this.
So I developed cosmological natural
selection to try to give an evolutionary
account of this so that there would be a
history back before the big bang.
And we see these numbers could change
and evolve through a series of events
like the Big Bang and there could be an
explanation akin to natural selection.
Just like you want to know why do people
have two legs and not three legs or five
legs or four legs or six legs.
There's an evolutionary reason for that.
A certain kind of fitness has been
improved over many,
many generations and similarly that
could be a notion of fitness of the laws
of nature should approve or many
generations and cosmological natural
selection was an example of the theory
of that kind.
I realized that the only methodology we
hadn't science or the best methodology,
we had science for explaining how
choices having made the system true lead
to a lot of structure because one of the
mysteries is why our universe is so
structured as it is on so many scales
from organic molecules.
Bio Molecules are too vast.
Arrays of clusters of galaxies.
This enormous structure on such a wide
range of scales and that turns out to be
tied to the values of these constants of
the Standard Model of particle physics.
And so why is that?
And I realized that the only methodology
that was really successful for
explaining how choice were made in
nature such as to lead to an improbable
amount of structure is natural
selection.
So for natural selection,
we need reproduction.
And it was a hypothesis lying around
that universities reproduced through
black holes inside black holes,
rather than there being singularities
we're time ends.
There were the,
basically the bursts of new regions of
space and time,
which could become new universes.
And I took over that hypothesis and took
over the hypothesis that maybe the laws
of nature changed slightly,
which has been made by Johnny Wheeler in
the 1960s and just added a little bit,
which is that those changes should be
very small,
that there can be accumulation of
fitness leads to a prediction or an
observation that archer,
many,
many generations,
the population of universities should be
fine tuned to maximize the production of
black holes.
And that has further implications for
things that we can actually try to
measure and disprove experimentally.
So that's very briefly the idea of
cosmological natural selection.
Okay.